you have to trust in something your gut
destiny life karma whatever because
believing that the dots will connect
down the road will give you the
confidence to follow your heart even
when it leads you off the well-worn path
it's really hard and you have to do it
over a sustained period of time so if
you don't love it if you're not having
fun doing it you don't really love it
you're gonna give up don't get caught up
in well I've tried it four or five times
and things didn't work out if there's
something that you want and you're
hungry for it you've got to do whatever
is necessary until and when you give the
best you can and that's not enough you
must do what is required
what this power is I cannot say all I
know is that it exists and it becomes
available only when a man or woman is in
that state of mind in which he or she
knows exactly what he or she walks and
is fully determined not to quit until
they find it
you've got to find what you love and
that is as true for work as it is for
your lovers and the only way to do great
work is to love what you do if you
haven't found it yet keep looking and
don't settle a warrior does not give up
what he loves he finds the love to what
he does
sometimes life's gonna hit you in the
head with a brick don't lose faith you
have to have a lot of passion for what
you're doing and it's totally true and
the reason is is because it's so hard
that if you don't any rational person
would give up someone's opinion of you
does not have to become your reality and
ladies and gentlemen I started working
on my dream and most people don't work
on their dreams why for many years I did
one is because of fear the fear of
failure what if things don't work out
and the fear of success what if they do
and I can't handle it
so keep thinking don't say because I
didn't believe in myself because I
allowed other people's opinion of me to
control my destiny I didn't act on my
ideas it's necessary that you align
yourself with people and attract people
into your business who are hungry people
who are unstoppable and unreasonable
people who are refusing to leave life
just as it is
it's necessary that you get the losers
out of your life if you are to live your
dream
remembering that you are going to die is
the best way I know to avoid the trap of
thinking you have something to lose
there is no reason not to follow your
heart your time is limited so don't
waste it living someone else's life that
some of you already know that it's hard
it's not easy it's hard changing your
life and in the process of working on
your dreams you are going to incur incur
a lot of disappointment a lot of failure
a lot of pain you can live your dream
the journey is not easy before you start
that journey mentally you must fuel
yourself with the right reasons the
right fuel to sustain the entire journey
everyone's hot awful start don't be
trapped by Dogma which is living with
the results of other people's thinking
don't let the noise of others opinions
drown out your own inner voice and most
important have the courage to follow
your heart and intuition they somehow
already know what you truly want to be P
we all fall down in life guys the
question is who gets back up